este es el mismo problema del vídeo
anterior solo que ahorita quiero
mostrarte otra forma de resolverlo para
ver que estos problemas de proporciones
se pueden hacer de más de una forma y
que todas estas nos dan la respuesta
correcta claro si hacemos todo bien voy
a volver a leer el problema dice una
pipa puede llenar una alberca 1.5 veces
más rápido que una segunda pipa si ambas
pipas están abiertas se llena en 6 horas
si solo a la pipa lenta está abierta
cuánto tiempo se tardará en llenar la
alberca bueno como te comentaba es muy
útil pensar en razones de llenado así
que déjame llamarle de alguna forma a la
razón de llenado de la pipa lenta
vale entonces vamos a pensar que la pipa
lenta llena r esta va a ser la razón de
llenado r albercas las albercas por
ahora por ahora entonces con esta
información podemos determinar la razón
de llenado de la pipa rápida la pipa
rápida porque el problema nos dice que
la pipa rapidez 1.5 veces más rápida así
que su razón de llenado sería 1.5 r
albercas por hora albercas
albercas por ahora muy bien y juntando
esta información podemos obtener la
razón combinada de llenado que voy a
poner por acá en otro color la combinada
y para esto simplemente tenemos que
sumar ambas razones la de la pipa lenta
y de la rápida así que nos quedaría que
la razón combinada es r más 1.5 r
albercas por hora albercas cercas por
hora muy bien esto lo podemos
simplificar un poco como 2.5 r albercas
por ahora simplemente sume albercas
albercas por ahora y ahora vamos a ver
qué otra información nos da el problema
nos dice que si ambas están abiertas
entonces se llena una alberca de esta
forma esta razón de llenado es igual a
la razón de llenado que nos dan acá
arriba es decir a una alberca alberca
una alberca cada seis horas
horas muy bien ahora podemos igualar 2.5
r a un sexto porque aquí tenemos las
mismas unidades y de esta forma
obtenemos que 2.5 ere 2.5 r
la razón de llenado de la pipa lenta la
pipa lenta es igual a un sexto y aquí
dividiendo entre 2.5 de ambos lados acá
y acá 2.5 obtenemos que r es igual a 1
entre 6 por 2.5 y 6 por 2.5 es 15
entonces r es igual a 1 entre 15 y por
lo tanto la razón de llenado de la pipa
lenta es uno entre 15 no voy a poner
aquí arriba esto que nos dice nos dice
que se llena un quinceavo de alberca por
ahora y de esta forma tardaríamos 15
horas en llenar una alberca vamos a ver
si eso responde la pregunta nos
preguntan cuánto tiempo se tardará en
llenar la alberca si solo la pipa lenta
está abierta a pues si eso es justo lo
que hicimos entonces se tardaría 15
y horas muy bien entonces es exactamente
el mismo problema del vídeo anterior
sólo que aquí está resuelto de otra
forma que creo que es un poco más
sencilla pero a lo mejor no vale la pena
no vale la pena hacer la comparación
porque en el otro vídeo expliqué más
cosas bueno espero que te haya gustado
nos vemos hasta la próxima